all right
thank you so much you guys for having me i'm very excited for this class actually
one of my favorite topics is purification of the heart just because of how functional it
is and how important it is for us to have it in our in our life
and be able to understand okay this is what it means to purify ourselves this is
what it means uh to be a better person and to try and to to try
and to be better and get closer to allah before we get started inshallah i wanted
to go over the class syllabus i understand there's some people who are just watching live
um this is for you too if you decide to join us but uh yeah i
just wanted to go to the class syllabus really quickly so i will share my screen
here
um can everybody see this very well
perfect okay so the very first thing is that this class will happen every other wednesday
a very important note is the time because i myself actually forgot the time just now
like i i'm okay so i'm actually i live in dallas i'm in atlanta right now
visiting my family and so um you know i was telling my mom i have class
at seven i kept saying i have class from seven to eight and i was like
literally adamant about it and something just told me to like check my phone and check
the time and i was like no that's that doesn't make sense do you have class
right now
and so important thing to note is the times from 5 to 6 pm uh central
time um in addition to that sometimes like if you have a follow-up question or if
something comes up in class and you don't really uh think about a question in class
um there's no problem you can just reach out to me email me at my email
that is right here at fox column institute uh dot org so that is the first
thing the second thing that we're going to cover here is our course description so purification
of the heart is actually in arabic is referred to as does here to nafs the
purification of the self or taskia to the purification of the heart and it's about you
know developing oneself to the point that they have this level or continuous level of god
consciousness and awareness of the lost fontella and we're going to talk more about this today
today is an introduction and we're going to talk about you know some of one of
the biggest diseases that takes us away from the remembrance of allah and we'll have a
better understanding of what it means to have this purity or to be have this god
consciousness in this awareness of allah now the importance of this is that this course has
um will always include quranic ayats for referencing will always always include a hadith and stories
from the life of the prophet
just because this is our pronged approach you know we are trying to understand how to
be better and how to get closer to allah and the only way to truly understand
how to be better and get closer to allah is by using allah's book and using
uh the the example of that book and that is the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
we will be basing a lot of our different topics off of the book by translated
by hansa youssef called purification of the heart as well as other resources okay so i
am a big proponent i'm a big um
uh i am a big fan of exposing different texts i think that's very important it's
very important to be able to go through different texts understand different texts
and also be able to have that level of what you would say like diversity you
know especially if it's out there we might as well use it so you will see
that actually when we go through the course breakdown there are some things that we're going
to talk about there not necessarily in this particular text but we may explore it from
another text and i will let you know um when when we do that inshallah
so that is the but the main book that we will be referencing is the purification
of the heart behind as well as some imam and gaza work and so on and
so forth a class method i am i would like i love to tell my students
before we start a class exactly what to expect from me because i don't i don't
want you guys to have any surprises um and i also don't want you guys to
be very confused i love my personality so i will let students know very clearly that
i'm the type of instructor that likes to ask questions so none of my questions are
rhetorical
by any means they're not rhetorical so if if i ask a question and we're all
very silent we're just going to have a very awkward during the explore moment like it
will be very awkward i feel the awkwardness you feel the awkwardness we all feel the
awkwardness it's just better just you know answer the question you're saying um sometimes i may
ask a question and maybe two people answered and i'll say okay let's get to five
you know and i really need it i sincerely need it in my heart let's get
to five so you know before we all are sitting in a very awkward silence in
our own rooms or homes let's just answer questions in that way um if someone has
a question there will be ample time amount of time for questions after the session but
we can all i also don't mind taking questions during the session so i pay a
lot of attention to the chat and as i said that i realized i didn't actually
pull up the chat this time but i pay a lot of attention to the chat
so if you guys have questions then i would definitely take your questions uh from the
chat as well um and then lastly
i understand that you know zoom everybody has like a lot of zoom fatigue and like
you know a lot of your classes are probably on zoom and so a lot of
people may want to keep their cameras off and so on and so forth and if
that makes you more comfortable by all means go ahead and do so but because we
want to have the most the best experience ever and we want to make sure that
it's like very close to in-person experience it really help out a lot if you guys
keep your cameras on in the class um just so i can see your expressions too
you know seeing your expressions help me understand whether or not you understood the material or
i or are you just like quiet like you know i can feel the vibes a
little bit so make sure that if you are able to you come to the class
and you're ready to turn your cameras on right make sense any questions so far
feel free to nod your head good perfect i like lots of head mods very good
job all right so the first day of class today we're going to talk about the
introduction to verification questions on why are we here what are we doing here um every
at the end of every class i'm going to give you guys a little bit of
homework don't worry it's not something that you have to go and research and like come
back and like tell me like i'll bang my head in the door for five hours
i couldn't find the answer it's not that type of homework it's going to be a
little bit of homework on working on yourself just a lot of reflection stuff if someone
wants to share in the next class feel free to share but no but i'm not
because this journey is a very personal journey um no one has to you're not forced
to share you're not uh it's not something i'm gonna force you to do i'm gonna
tell you like oh like you're a bad student because you didn't share your feelings that's
fine you don't have to but the homework is something that you should think about doing
um after every class because that will help in being able to really make the material
that we're learning very practical inshallah so the first class is introduction
and then we'll also talk about guffler and i'll explain what that means so as you
can see the different diseases that we're going to cover are actually broken down into sections
right so they're not just one disease per week we're going to cover a multitude of
sections and how the reason why is because a lot of times when we cover just
one one one we don't get through a lot of materials right so if we just
covered one of these every week then we'll cover like four diseases of the heart but
so we can get through a good amount of material we're grouping them into different sections
so the very first thing we're going to tackle is our battle against ourselves right and
the the reason why it's called battles i really like analogies and you guys are going
to see this a lot i really enjoy analogies because i feel like they bring things
to life and so life is a struggle life is a war and we're trying to
win the war the way that we win the war is by winning little battles okay
you win some you lose some and for us we're trying to win all of them
and the way that we're going to win all of these battles is by breaking down
the ballots into the understanding into a proper understanding of what we are even fighting so
sometimes you're trying to work on yourself but you don't even recognize what you're trying to
even fix and so first we're going to tackle the first battle the battle of our
self-image himself um and in that we'll talk about showing off vanity arrogance and materialism
and you will see how everything comes together don't worry um the second battle that we're
going to discuss which is on the third class will be the battle of body parts
so we'll talk about the eyes the ears and the tongue um and this is very
important we'll talk about it from a very particular aspect i will also talk about lusts
and boundaries and then we'll have a little bit of a break so you guys can
spend some time pondering over all the things we discussed we're just playing that's your spring
break so you can enjoy that um and then we'll talk about the battle of influences
so we'll talk about companionship entertainment recreational activities and envy and then lastly but not least
in our final final session we'll talk about the battle of tough times and battle tough
times is really our internal battle with things that we project onto our last one and
so we'll talk about that and we'll talk about gratefulness how that manifests relies on other
than a lot of resentment and anger now the thing about these all of these topics
is inshallah we'll have a section at the end where we will be able to um
at the end of every class before further questions we'll be able to make sure that
we are taking some practical steps um and applying them to our lives make sense everybody
any questions so that is the that is the syllabus the class syllabus any questions nope
all right so another thing about me i should feel like this class is all about
me another thing about me is that i have the tendency to talk very fast
if i am talking too quickly and i say hey guys am i talking too fast
am i going too fast you do not have to lie actually this class is working
on not lying right so you can just tell me just slow down a little bit
oh yes that was too fast okay you go back to the previous slide can you
repeat what you said i have no problem that's not i don't find it annoying i
don't find it weird i am perfectly fine with that so fall down can go back
so on and so forth that's great make sense
all right
is being polite equal no big time doesn't equal lying um but if i say am
i going too fast you can say just a little bit that's still play you know
and i say am i going too fast and you're like no you're going at the
perfect speed meanwhile everyone's like dying trying to take notes and that's a little problematic just
a little bit
alrighty so we are learning the purification of the heart
the outline that we're going to be discussing today is one why are we here the
second thing is the dynamic trio and we'll understand how this leads into one another so
islam iman and
and then lastly today we will cover the reality of life it seems like this is
a short class it seems like oh that's not we'll be done soon there's a lot
to cover there's a lot to talk about and i'm excited to be on this journey
with you guys and i'm excited that you guys are attentive and already you know very
active so that makes me very happy so we will be covering a good amount of
material um before we get into the material i have one more disclaimer and that last
disclaimer is that we're all home and because we're all home that means all of our
families are home as well so if at some point someone comes in and they're like
talking to me it's probably one of my brothers um they have no concept of me
teaching the class they actually don't care um so they may ask me for water and
they ask me if is food ready they may ask me where's mom they may ask
me anything so i just would like to apologize ahead of time um this is like
my life i'm just like pre-apologizing for my sibling but yes i like to apologize ahead
of time because they're all home everybody's off from work now so inshallah hopefully nobody will
come in but if that happens we're just going to roll with it we're going to
act like it never happened it's going to keep it going
before we can talk about
the purification or talk about diseases that we face the diseases of the heart that we
face on our daily life we have to understand our purpose and you if you don't
understand your purpose then you're not able to what you what we will say uh understand
your morals and your values you know then those become very up in the air and
because we have in the quran where washington tells us exactly why we are created and
our purpose in life then gives this helps us out a lot you know we're not
just sitting down trying to figure it out from thin air rather we recognize that allah
gives us that lost mentality is giving us our way of life and while times giving
us our worldview so last month
mankind except to worship the very first thing is that our purpose in life is worship
that is our purpose our purpose in life is to worship allah so you will see
that in the quran many times when allah
introduces himself to himself to prophets he will tell them that you should worship me or
you should pray for my remembrance for example when he introduced himself to musa islam allah
then told muslim that musa islam should pray lee dickery he says
establish prayer for my remembrance right so allah will constantly
uh introduce himself with the understanding giving us the understanding of our responsibility to allah now
worship but something that's so beautiful about that is that it manifests in different ways so
that's what allah will say
right all you who believe and do good deeds because part of belief is acting upon
it and worshiping and that worship manifests in different ways but the thing is when we're
worshiping allah allah is now giving us a deed he gives us our religion okay allah
teaches us how to worship him and that is through islam and islam is our religion
so allah says
islam but the only true demon in the sight of god is self-surrender is one who
submits himself now notice
what word did i not translate here
what word is not
translated
right so am i just i i'm not going to just leave you guys hanging like
yeah dean let's move on no i didn't translate the word dean because so many times
the word deen is translated as religion which is hybrid
but the way that we understand it as muslim muslims is that deen is actually your
way of life okay deen is your way of life it is how you eat it
is how you eat it is what you say before you eat it is how you
wake up it is how you dress is how you act it is how you interact
with your family it is how you pray it is what you say when you go
to sleep is how you sleep so the prophet says i'm telling us that when you
sleep you should sleep on your right hand side is teaching us how to implement our
deen it's teaching us how to implement our way of life so us worshiping allah
gives us our world view because the lost foreign gives us the deen and the being
is the way that we worship allah and that is your world view so some so
many times we have a conversation of dean versus dunya when in reality
when in reality the true conversation is how do i exist in this dunya because allah
did put me here in this world how do i exist in this world to the
liking and to the uh to the liking and to the utmost um what you could
say pleasure of allah
and the way that you do that is through your deen it is through your way
of life it is through your world view and so understanding that your world view the
only world view that lost allah accepts in the sight of him in the sight of
allah the only true world view is islam the only true way of living the only
the only way that of living that gives the pleasure of allah is islam and we'll
talk about islam a lot more because it it it built into this trio but when
we see it here in this particular ayah it means one who submits themselves to god
it means one who submits themselves to allah and so that's important to recognize too because
allah says that he didn't create mankind origin except to worship him and part of worship
is submission because there are some times where there will be things and we'll talk about
them they will come up in our conversations and show up but there'll be sometimes there'll
be things that we may not understand that allah has mandated but we have to submit
to it and so how do you get yourself to that point that's also a conversation
as well especially in that last section that we will discuss
so our entire dean is built up on three things our whole religion is built in
three things our whole deen
is built built sorry my mom i thought my mom was calling me um our whole
dean is built into three things it is built on iran and is built on islam
and is built on sm do these three things sound familiar to you guys
yeah you've heard of them before yes very
these three things are actually detailed
in what's called the hadith of gibral and in this particular hadith process psalm is is
choice a later part of the life of the prophet son and the prophet of term
is sitting with his companions okay the prophet samuel is sitting with his companions and as
he's sitting with the companions what happens is that uh a man comes and um
who is narrating this he says a man came who looked like he never traveled okay
he didn't look like he came from afar he didn't look like he traveled but rather
he came and he
rather he came and he just sat next to the prophet son he sent in from
the process and he put his hands on the props of someone's thighs okay and um
also narrates that he says we didn't know this guy we didn't know him we didn't
know him at all and you know how um
he was very protective
so he was not okay with this guy who just came and just started you know
you know like you see somebody random like walk up to your friend and just hug
them you're like hold on i didn't know you were part of the group who are
you what's your name where'd you come from what's your address why do you think you're
like friends with us like and then later on you're like questioning your friend like who
was that are y'all really close or yeah somewhere close what are we doing is this
for somebody we're going to meet all the time like that's
very protective over the prom start them so the story goes and this man starts asking
questions he asks him what is iman after some answers yeah and then the man says
seduct oh you told the truth after the process and we'll answer he would say you
told the truth and um is getting a little bit more like annoyed because that of
course the prophet saw i'm told the truth and towards the second question he says the
same thing and he realized oh the processor must be teaching us something so he takes
a step back and he really pays attention after this man leaves the process and returns
he asked him do you know who that was and um
who says no allah and his messenger know best and the prophet psalm said that was
the angel jabel he came to teach you your deen and so that's how we understand
that our religion is comprised of these three things it is iman it is islam and
it is confined
very beautiful right oh the very first thing is iman i like i'm a semi nerd
i'm a fake nerd i like to nerd out on things that just you know mean
something to me if it doesn't then i don't know that on it words in arabic
the arabic language does not do it for me like i'm not like i don't nerd
out on the arabic language but i wouldn't nerd out on specific words in the arabic
language it's very strange we'll see it in our entire journey here together so the word
iman we'll talk about words when arabic words throughout the class and we'll make sure to
talk about them from both this linguistic standpoint and from a technical standpoint and a technical
standpoint is when we're understanding something in regards to the science that we're learning okay so
technical standpoint is when you're understanding something in regards to or connect it to the science
that particular science that you're learning so for example in al
iran has a particular meaning in fact iman has a particular meaning we are learning specifications
we are learning the purification of the self so we're gonna learn iman uh islam and
exams from our understanding in this particular science make sense
yep okay so the linguistic meaning of the word even it actually comes from the root
of hamza
noon okay and it has a meaning of safety it has a meaning of safety and
its root it has the meaning of safety and something interesting is that the scholars say
that and iman the way we understand it is faith we understand it as faith we
understand it as belief right so the scholars say that the connection between the word safety
and iman is that safety brings a sense of calmness to one's heart and similar to
how when someone feels safe their heart is calm their heart is able to like you
know live his life um when someone has faith that faithfulness brings a calmness to their
heart as well that faithfulness that belief brings a calmness to their hearts and so you
will see it in the manifestation of both good times and tough times sometimes when things
are very tough you find yourself you know feeling like you're at your wit's end you
may be back to a corner and then maybe after the fifth or fourth today of
struggling and really stressing about this you realize you have no control over it and you
just break down and like make that dual to a lot and like you're still stressing
your head but your heart just feels a little bit calmer that is faithfulness that's that's
that faithfulness and for some people it takes years for some people it's like a two-day
thing for some people it's like the moment something bad happens they're like in the hands
of the law like they really truly mean it you know so everybody has their different
um ways of of it's manifesting
i lost month all that says
and they do not cover up their belief with wrongdoing or they do not cover up
their belief with with shirk or wrongdoing
for those people specifically they have safety
and they are the ones who are truly guided so while says that your iman brings
you safety it brings you a sense of comfort it brings you a sense of safety
a man is our foundation
it is our world view and it means that we accept allah as the one and
only god and we accept that things that there is a reality to the unseen even
though we cannot see it and we also uh accept that the prophet is the messenger
and that he has informed us about these particular things so this is iman
any questions so far
all right am i going too fast
all right
next is
islam islam and its root it comes from um islam in its root it comes from
alif
i'm sorry
right and it has the meaning of being sincere
and being devoted to something has a meaning of being sincere and being devoted to something
there's not an an arabic text for islam this time because we've already covered that in
the ayah that came second the second ayah where allah says the only true deen is
islam
so islam is actually the way that we can understand it in the purification of the
heart and the way that we can too many of our professors talk too slow so
i love this you captioning not
and i'm like available half the time like let's get to it you know let's get
let's get through this so yeah so then i found myself actually speaking faster and so
now i'm like you already speak fast in your natural self please don't like ruin someone
like by like super sweet and speaking so yes
um so islam is it what we can understand it as is we understand it as
our devotion to allah understand it as our submission to allah and we understand it as
our manifestation of our religion okay we is the the different one of the ways that
our belief manifests and what that means is that it comprises of a series of actions
that we do and it's not limited to ritual so you're normally when we talk about
submission we think or we talk about practical implementation implementation
of the religion a lot of times we think that it's just prayer you know you
just pray and you just fast but it's not limited to the ritual acts in fact
there's there's your social conduct how you are with other people how you are with your
family it is your etiquette it is how you speak it is how you treat your
neighbors this is how the the manifestation of the self and so this is the practical
application of our religion what's very interesting is that this is this topic or this section
of our religion we're going to explore it some more because
this is where you get the remedies for the different diseases you get the remedies for
the diseases of the heart from your practice in your religion so for instance if we
were taught to talk about um if we were to talk about you know maybe treating
family better how do we do that we'll explore in the quran the different way or
the quran and the sunnah the different ways of how we are to treat our family
members depending upon different situations and so on and so forth and so these this is
where you get the remedy for your for the different diseases of the heart
lastly the last thing that our religions comprise of is
okay and this is where we're spending the bulk of our time studying this is the
goal this is where we're studying this is what we're going to be spending our time
on
in this essence it comes from ha
noon and it means to beautify something it means to beautify something and what's so beautiful
about it is that when jibril alayhi salam came to the prophet sallam in that hadith
of jubal he asked prophet sallallahu alaihi sand what is the prophet answered him and he
says
is to worship allah as if you can see him okay
is to worship allah as if you can see him in them
but even though you cannot see him
know that he can see you that is what exxon is and i like to think
about like when we were little and you know we would live in the house with
our parents and stuff and like when our parents was around you know your mom your
dad when they're around and they tell you to clean something you like clean it to
the best of your ability like you do like you know you get corners you do
all the stuff you're supposed to do with your mom or your dad's at the store
and they're like make sure you clean the kitchen you know you just slap things around
hide things in places whatever the case may be that's kind of how it is it's
like what the process i'm saying that is the true meaning of fsn is when you
manifest your belief as if you can see allah as if you can see him and
so you spend so much time beautifying yourself and exemplifying your heart and your soul so
that you know you're going to god in the best form thought possible so allah could
say yes that is my servant that is my faith that is the one who is
doing the best they can you know because you want that pleasure you want the thought
of allah
so part of a fan okay part of essen is that you have to recognize your
vices you have to recognize what triggers you you have to recognize you have to start
in recognizing okay this is what this is my downfall not complete downfall but this is
where i need to work i need to work this is where i need to uh
make things better this is where i need to fix this situation i need to stop
doing this i need to stop lying or maybe if it's cheating someone or maybe if
it's you know i don't know maybe if it's um maybe you have anger problems maybe
there's so many different things we're all a working progress and part of being a work
in progress is that you fix the work and you are in progress of of fixing
it right a or working progress doesn't mean you just accept the work that needs to
be done they're like okay we'll get to it when we get to it no you're
actually in the park process of fixing it sam so many people translate it as perfection
and it does not mean perfection
stand is not to be perfect it is to do the best that you can that's
why allah the prophet saw says
for you to worship allah that is something that is in the present future tense it
means that you're being consistent in it you're consistently worshipping allah you're consistently trying to do
better because you know that god can see you that's what it is and it does
not need to be perfect because the procession also says that every single human being it
makes has flaws every single human being makes mistakes right and part of essen are beautifying
oneself is toba art of toba is recognizing that you've made a mistake part of making
mistakes means that you're not perfect so our religion teaches us that we don't have to
be perfect but we are striving to be the best versions of ourselves okay so every
single one of you guys that are here today and i'm giving you your goals because
i can i think every single one of you are working you guys are all working
on being the best version of yourself you're not trying to be like the person next
to you you're not trying to be like the guy across the street you're not trying
to be like the girl you know down in your other class because you think she's
like the perfect muslim in the world you're not trying to be like nobody else you're
trying to be the best version of yourself because allah created you guys i love that
i gave you your personality
made you who you are so you have the potential to be the best person you
have the potential to be a great person and you have to recognize that and part
of recognizing it is that yes i have some amazing qualities about me i also have
some things i need to work on so every day i'm going to strive to be
the best version of myself and that is if sam teaches us to always present our
best our best in accordance to us not in accordance to what society tells you not
in accordance to what someone else tells you if someone else tells you no your best
is this they don't know you they don't know what your best is they don't know
what you can handle they don't know what you can put out so you have to
take an honest look at yourself and see what is my best and how can i
put my best foot forward okay so that is the introduction pretty long right
the very first thing that
yep we have to work on that raw material absolutely and that's why i love sponsor
tells musa alayhi salam it's such a beautiful story musam is one of my favorite prophets
um we're probably i'm trying to bring him up so many times in my conversation you
guys are going like does she know any other prophets i promise i do i just
really love the sorry islam story and so last one time tells musa islam through his
life as things are going things are happening and things are moving too fast for him
or he thinks he can't handle it and if i can't handle this message can handle
this mission is too much last one that says and he tells muslims
we've tested you in many different ways and the word button the word that for testing
it actually means like where raw materials convert it into like um raw materials converted into
diamonds or pressure is made to make something so beautiful right and so alaska puts us
in certain situations for us to come out as our best selves you know and sometimes
before you come out as your best self there's a lot of ugly that's around there
and then you come on you're like wow okay this is what i was meant to
learn here what one of the very first things that we're talking about now is we're
going to talk about guffler because the scholars talk about how guffler and i'll don't worry
i will explain conflict to you guys until you're like i want to hear about gulfplant
no more
one of the roots of all of our issues because we talked about our purpose of
life right our purpose is light of life is to worship allah and part of worshiping
a lot is part of worshiping a lot the way to worship allah is through deen
and our deen comprises of three things islam
and iran right and so gafla is when someone is taking away from that when someone
is taken away from their purpose that is what gofla is it is when someone has
taken away from their purpose and when you're taken away from your purpose and you are
not remembering your morals and your values it is much easier to fall into traps of
shaytan
and that's why they say that gupta is the root of all diseases right
the prophet muhammad
he
says
he squats at the heart of a human being and what this means is that he's
a lurking he's a there he's around he's just waiting for you to mess up he
wants you to like not pay attention for
whenever
uh the human being mentions allah there's a little bit of a typo here i didn't
translate the second line sorry about that but whenever the human being mentions allah then shaitan
runs away he goes he's like man this person they're on it they're remembering god
but when they're neglectful in that when they're golfers when they're neglectful in that or when
they are forgetful in that regard
then that is when he makes his evil suggestions that is when he says his evil
things buffalo
it's not just something that occurs in one way it's not just one singular thing you're
just not in like the ultimate state of gotham once you experience it one time absolutely
not
i like to i understand that right now we're in like coronavirus and stuff so i
should not be comparing things to diseases but i told you guys i love analogies and
analogies help us to understand and now the analogy of gus gupla is that buffalo is
actually like a disease think of it as a disease and it's something it's a type
of virus that if you let it sit it will mutate into something worse okay it
will mutate into some something worse so a gulf life as a virus it first starts
off as forgetfulness
you're very forgetful you just and you know forgetfulness is not necessarily on purpose right you're
just you're doing something something comes up you forget whatever the case may be so gulf
left first manifest as forgiveness
if you don't get a hold of your forgetfulness
then it will become neglectful
and neglectful the difference between someone tell me what is the difference between forgetfulness in the
club and being neglectful
consciousness
consciousness yes that is
i was just trying to pull up the participants list just in case anybody raises their
hand yes it is consciousness when you forget something
yes when you forget something it's unintentional when you're neglectful that is very intentional
but then if you let that neglectfulness sit you have now mutated that virus into a
void of feeling at least when you neglect something and it can be intentional you may
still feel like you have an obligation to that thing but gulf la in its worst
form is when someone actually has the feeling that actually this is not even my responsibility
in the first place let's take salah for example sometimes you may one may forget to
pray and that happens every once in a while somebody may forget to play now if
they don't get a hold of it and start setting reminders from themselves including it into
their schedule whatever the case may be then it can turn into neglectfulness where at the
end of the day you're like man today i didn't get to it tomorrow you know
today i didn't get to tomorrow you don't even put in any type of effort you're
sitting down you're maybe you know doing your work or whatever the case may be it's
time to pray you're saying okay well tomorrow i'll pray all my prayers you just push
it off the next day constantly
that mutates to someone saying i don't even need to pray it can mutate into someone
saying i don't need to pray
in its essence guppy is also sometimes
not using things for the purpose that it should be used for or not using things
to the best of its ability or to its benefit
and so this is the first thing that we have to make sure that we this
is the first thing that we have to make sure that we fix and we're going
to talk about how to fix it because
we the way that we fix it
is uh the way that we fix it is through understanding the reality of life imam
ghazali is one of the most amazing
scholars
ever and he has a lot of analogies which is probably why i enjoy his work
so much whenever i can decipher their analogies and he has this particular analogy of the
reality of life if rama gandali he talks he tells a story about a time where
he met a traveler okay he was traveling himself he met another traveler traveler asked him
he said tell me about life tell me what is the reality of life when ghazali
then replied to this traveler and he says to him okay he replies to this traveler
he says to him there was once a man and this man was in the jungle
right and this man was in the jungle and he was getting chased by a lion
once he started getting chased by the lion he started to run and he ran until
he found a well and when he found this well he jumped into the well i
don't know if you guys have ever seen a well before i'm from west africa so
i see wells all the time but basically well normally has like a little bit of
a rope he jumps into the well and he gets onto this rope he holds onto
the rope and he's about to lure himself down to the well when he sees a
snake at the bottom of the well so he's now in the middle because he's scared
he looks up and he's even more petrified because the lion is still there and then
he notices
that there are two mice nibbling at the uh the rope
and so now he's really flipping out because at the end of the day it's like
lying up top there's a snake at the bottom and the mice are eating at this
room and then imam ghazali says that the man looks to his left and he looks
his right and when he looks to his right he sees a pot of honey right
he sees a pot of honey and it's like so um it's like overflowing and so
he reaches out to eat the honey and then imam ghazali stops there so the traveler
says to imam ghazali what does that mean because like you okay i asked you about
the reality of life and you just told me about some man getting chased and imam
ghazali tells him pay attention he says that the lion is the angel of death and
no matter how much you try to outrun it it will eventually catch up with you
that the snake is your grave and is ready to have you and basically swallow you
and then he says and the two mice are the night and the day eating away
at your time
and he says that when you are un then when you are not aware of your
situation
he says that the the honey is the guffler it is just you just not being
aware of your situation
so imam ghazali says that this is life that sometimes we get distracted by so many
things around us that we don't recognize our true purpose and what we're supposed to be
doing and that is worshiping the law and so we cannot let gafla get in our
way so allah the way that gopher manifests allah says and he says
he said there we have created many men many genuine people who will go to hellfire
and the reason why is
that they have hearts but their heart does not it's not comprehensive they don't use it
they don't use their heart and your heart is your moral compass it is where your
future lies and recognizing that part of a compass is to take care of it if
you do not take care of a compass then it takes you off course so alessandra
this is the example of those who are heedless or those who are neglectful
so
before we go on to the last slide
see i'm doing good have 10 minutes or questions so before we go on to the
last slide
the way that we are going to work on fixing our guffler
is it's a working progress okay it's a work in progress it is not something that
developed overnight remember we talked about how guffler is actually a virus
it's not something that developed overnight it's not something that developed in one second it took
time and just like it took time reversing it would take a little bit of time
the first thing that we're going to focus on is mindfulness it is so important for
us to be mindful of our time to be mindful of the things that we are
doing to be mindful of what we're saying and it's just a very mindless exercise in
the sense that when you are when you do something just think to yourself why did
i do what i did okay when you're using your time think about what you're using
your time with one of the biggest things one of the best ways to be able
to do this especially for salah in aspects of salah is writing down what you do
throughout your day okay these are all the things that i have to do today these
are all the things that i did do and you can see where your time is
going you can see where your time is going yes sometimes what happens is that we
may write out a to-do list we may even write down that we need to pray
or something like that and then we say oh we're going to watch this one i'm
let me just scroll on instagram real quick and scrolling on instagram is never a real
quick situation i don't know who lied to you and who told you it is but
it's not because you're saying that i only watched six videos
each video is one minute long
okay each video is one minute long because videos are so short you think that okay
this is i didn't spend that much time doing it next thing you know and god
forbid you come across an igtv video that's like 11 minutes and two minutes into it
you're already invested so you feel like you got to watch the whole thing even if
you don't like it that's where your time is going so it's so important to understand
where your time is going and where you're spending that time the second thing is if
someone is neglectful with their salah it is so important that that's the first thing that
you're working on the very first thing that you're working on is your salah and how
you're going to work on that is you're going to schedule time to pray i understand
it sounds very strange why do i have to schedule in time to pray well you
schedule time to go to class schedule time to talk to your friends you schedule time
to hang out with your family you can schedule time to talk to god you schedule
it in you write it down you have it you see it you know a lot
of times out of sight out of mind right if you're not getting an event notification
and honestly on college campuses it becomes very awkward to get an event notification so if
you're not getting an exam notification you're not getting you know you're not your parents are
not telling you to pray like all these things be served as reminders for us growing
up all of a sudden we don't have those reminders anymore so out of sight out
of mind you don't want to do that to yourself write it down make it a
part of your schedule figure it out try to even see how what is the prayer
that you're most commonly missing and then see what is happening in that exact time and
why is it happening in that exact time and what can i do to fix it
you know so really take a critical analysis of oneself and try to see how you
can fix that because prayer is the very first thing that we're going to do okay
now homework for you guys this is your homework portion and then we'll get to some
final questions very first homework is that you all should spend time just making dua for
yourself the very first thing you need to do is you need to make dua for
yourself and part of making dua for yourself is that one you ask a lot to
open up your heart to this journey number two you ask montala to make things easy
on you number three ask last month to give you what's called himmla or the consistency
and the energy to be able to work on yourself and number four you ask a
lot to purify your intentions and then whatever other do i want to make you should
definitely make it but make dua for yourself a lot of times we spend so much
time making well for everybody else our parents our friends this and that we forget to
make very personal dwells for ourselves so make duals for yourself the second thing is set
your intention why are you here why are you here and what do you want to
do with with yourself how how do i want to be the best spot what do
i want to get out of this what are the things that i need to work
on and part of making your intention is knowing your why and so when you know
your why why am i doing this then you're able to make your proper intention on
how to be better the third thing is understand the stakes and what this means is
that life is a work in progress okay so some weeks you guys may see yourself
making a lot of progress you may fill the class you may feel like okay tomorrow
i'm going to be on it and then you're on it for three days and then
one day you may take a dip and that's okay it happened it happens but you
don't give up there you don't stay at the dip you don't stay there gotta get
back up you gotta try again so understand mistakes understand that that you know this is
for the sake of allah and for the sake of the pleasure of allah and since
that's the case then we have to make sure that we are giving ourselves setting ourselves
up our success and part setting ourselves up for success is knowing that there may be
times where it may be very difficult and lastly spend some time reflecting if you're not
into journaling i will suggest you know just take the duration of this class it's not
not telling your journal for the rest of your life but take the duration of this
class journal about yourself what are some things you need to work on what are some
things you know you like about yourself and this is not a pessimistic class okay we're
not here saying like we're all the worst people in the world because we're not and
god has given us all amazing qualities so what are some great qualities that you have
that you feel like you can you know you can use what are some great qualities
that you have you feel like you've been neglecting and you haven't been you know seeing
yourself in the most positive light write those down too and see how this is about
just being the best right it's about being the best so that is your homework for
the week
or yeah because i will see you guys in a couple of weeks yes make sense
all right let's get to some final questions before we end i don't like to take
anyone's time um so i like to use the exact time that i've been given i'm
trying to take i don't like to go over so um let's do questions
how do i reverse scuffle with void of feeling sadly i have reached a state and
some aspects of my iman and it makes me fearful you know that's a very good
question how do i reverse gulf law avoid a feeling the very first thing is that
we are recognizing that we are here for the purpose of allah and part of recognizing
that is that we have to get to know allah a lot of times we have
this void of failing because we have a we feel like we have a very far
distance between us and the last one fella but it's because we don't know him we
haven't spent some time getting to kill him i would suggest one this class will definitely
help in knowing more things about allah
and allah's nature and his characteristics and things of that nature but also uh spend some
time reading about the 99 names of allah yeah that also helps on there's a website
called virtual mosque yeah there's a website called virtual mosque and this lady i forgot her
name she did a phenomenal job on the names of the last month i think she
even converted it into a book on amazon so i should probably be re referring people
there but i don't know the name of the book but virtual monster is a book
i mean there's a series of names of allah
how can i
excuse me siri how rude how can we apply this concept when we forget araka in
prayer so when you forget a long time in prayer that may be that may be
like forgive from this but it's not necessarily completely all the time neglectfulness um but one
thing to do is get your mind in the mindset of prayer you know a lot
of times we're rushing so we rush to pray and what happens is that when you
rush to pray you're not necessarily comprehending that you're praying so if you have like a
really busy schedule make sure you take out time to make wudu before every prayer that's
going to help you like calm down before you start praying and then that will also
remedy in a forgetting forgetting raqqa and different things in the quran i mean in in
your salah
is this the same use of gopher yes this is the same use of the guppy
and we're going to actually cover there's an ayah
belinda
we're going to cover this ayah in the next class so i'm going to wait until
the next class to actually talk about this one
okay
will this recording be available for lego viewing i think
so
i'm folk i'm struggling with focusing in my prayer i start off strong then my mind
begins to wonder how do i fix this focus in prayer actually starts i believe
so from uh lots of research focus when you want to focus in something you have
to work on it outside of that moment right so focusing in prayer gets better when
you're able to focus on other things outside of prayer so for example when you're having
a conversation with somebody are you on your phone while you talk to them because that's
not focusing on the conversation sure it can be a really casual conversation but it's fine
but when you're really talking to somebody you should practice mindfulness then you should practice working
on you know uh your brain focusing on one thing at a time and that will
help your focus and salah another thing is learning the definitions of the duas and the
different ayat and stuff like that that will also help as well and then classes like
this will also help develop that focus even more remember that it's a work in progress
you're not going to just develop in one day it takes time you're training your brain
to think a certain way you're training your brain to act a certain way and you're
training your body and yourself to be receptive to that what you're doing so it will
take a little bit of time so do not beat yourself up about it but that
is one way that it can happen
all right any other questions
nope
see any hands race all righty well thank you guys so much um how do we
work on being patient we'll talk about that in the upcoming classes so patience is a
remedy in one of the other classes so we'll talk about that there um i do
not know how to pronounce your name also
moment
who has their hand raised you may ask yourself how do you pronounce your name
maybe you don't have a question also yes what is your question do you have a
question you raise your hand
you can unmute if you want or you can type it in the
group
i have a question um you know when we're talking when i think about understanding the
stakes i'm thinking more in terms of am i going to heaven or am i going
to hell
so it's for me that's more like the i guess the ultimate
goal
yeah that can be one way to think about it um but also you know another
way to think about it is
for the pleasure of allah you know thinking about having that closeness that relationship with the
last one because at the end of the day that's what we're focused on right working
on making sure that we're fulfilling the duty that allah has commanded us to and that
is worshipping him you know thinking of heaven and how it works for some people but
it doesn't work for everybody sometimes for some people thinking about how it gives them a
lot of anxiety and it actually pushes them further away that's why last month i give
so many examples in the quran to help us understand our purpose that's at first some
people they're fear motivated for some people they're goal oriented and so it that's the beauty
of god right he uh appeals to every person in what way that is best for
them to be able to fix their fix themselves and work on themselves so yeah if
that's the stakes for you then that's the stakes for you that's why the homework is
so personal can you guys tell because if that's mistakes for you then and that works
for you that victory but for someone else it may be a little bit different okay
thank you don't worry thank you so much for sharing i'm sorry i don't know about
this is but then we speak about called saleem we have not talked about goblin salem
because we're going to talk about that throughout the class um it's not a one-time conversation
it's a conversation that's going to happen throughout because that's what we're working on so every
class will talk about a different understanding of the heart and then we'll also get into
a disease
make sense
any other questions actually i have one more question you know when we're talking about carbon
saline what about the mind doesn't the mind like control our heart
so actually that's a different conversation that's not it's um it's a very interesting conversation but
some say that the mind does control the heart some say it doesn't but the uncle
so some think that the alcohol the logic or reasoning lies in your mind when really
it lies in your heart um and so the understanding is that your heart is your
fitrah which is your moral compass and you are to use your mind to take care
of it
okay
does that make sense so if nothing stands alone you use everything to work everything works
together
okay
any other questions
um i had a really or can you actually you said to re you said to
pray or dua for four things when we when we're fixing our guffler could you repeat
those please
well these dwarves are not only forgotten they're for everything so for the entire journey so
do i first it's for a loss one time to open your heart to it
the second is for allah to give you the strength to work through it the third
is that last one time purifies your intentions
and then the fourth is that allah
um the fourth i don't remember the fourth one anybody get the fourth one down just
completely is it intentions
i already did that purify your intentions
maybe there's one more to make things easy for us make things easy very cool thank
you so much you're welcome